today in the ocean a life-or-death
battle between two extremely capable
predators first up is the stonefish the
killer who hides in plain sight with
sharp spines containing enough venom to
kill a person we've chosen a shot of it
missing its prey
I'm skeptical its opponent the Moray Eel
it's toxic skin and sharp teeth are
battle tested and ready to hunt I know
where I'm placing my bets let's see how
things play out as the eel dodges the
venomous spine of the stone fish he
sinks his teeth in and doesn't let go
not off to a good start stone fish as
the eel skin comes in contact with its
wounded prey the toxin excruciating Lee
destroys its red blood cells okay stone
fish is gonna need to mount a comeback
here the assault isn't over though as
the eel clamps down a second pair of
jaws deep inside its throat slides up to
chew the meal and that is alien
that is the xenomorph from alien can be
licensed some footage of alien to put up
alongside this ah no I'm being told no
we cannot afford it we begun entangling
the fish in its body the eel is then
able to tear off more manageable chunks
there are about 200 kinds of moray eels
throughout the world
some chase their prey while others
prefer to lie and wait note to the
scriptwriter be careful without your
titling this I don't know about like
battle between two capable predators
when one is just going to sort of stomp
all over the other I'm just saying
[Music]